I think what you're seeing with chat GPT
is just the tip of the iceberg and how
you're going to think
that you will increasingly go to your
device and you're going to be following
that device you'll get better advice out
of your device than you your own
thoughts and you're going to see it
happened in an enormous number of areas
for example
you know it used to be that you needed
to know something about math an
arithmetic and then you get a calculator
then you evolve information you used to
have to remember
um things nowadays you can so easily
look up all history it's at your device
now you're going to more and more be
able to say what is the best thinking
who is the best thinking where am I
going to get the best thinking what can
be done and you'll be following the
instructions on your device and I think
that that's not a bad thing this is a
good thing in many ways because it
elevates us it's part of an evolutionary
process in which technology is
increasingly replacing parts of man you
know the physical you in the in the old
days the man physical labor matter more
and more than machines replace that and
as we go and Ascend to higher and higher
levels of thinking that the brain
increasingly is being able to use and
that raises you because you can then
think about how do I think what are the
principles so for example if you think
about principles and I think about those
this tool in the form of principles you
can go get the best principles from
wherever they may come and consider them
them and then also make your own
principles so I think all of this helps
to elevate us but it's going to change
the dimension of the world that we're in